can I begin by thanking our national
secretary Lorna Finn and also can I
thank our headquarters staff for all the
incredible efforts that they have made
right throughout this process
it is hard for me to find the words to
describe just how honored I am to be
entrusted by our membership of the SNP
to be the parties next leader and to be
on the cusp of being our country's next
first minister
can I begin by paying tribute to my
colleagues both Kate and Ash during
almost 20 hostings it's probably fell
like we've seen each other more than we
have our respective families you both
have put in an incredible shift and I
know that collectively we will continue
to work hard as part of Team SNP
I am not just humbled of that I most
certainly am I also feel like the
luckiest man in the world to be standing
here as a leader of the SNP a party I
joined almost 20 years ago and that I
love so dearly
friends it was the late John Smith and
he got it absolutely right when he said
the opportunity to serve our country is
all we ask
to serve my country as first Minister
will be the greatest privilege in honor
of my life should Parliament decide to
elect me as Scotland's next first
Minister tomorrow
and just as I will lead the SNP in the
interests of all party members
not just those who voted for me so I
will aim to lead Scotland in the
interests of all of our citizens
whatever your political allegiance if
elected as your first Minister after
tomorrow's vote in Parliament know that
I will be a first Minister for all of
Scotland the I will work every minute of
every day to earn and to re-air your
respect and your trust
I will do that by treating you the
people of Scotland with respect
there will be no empty promises or easy
sound bites when the issues in front of
us are difficult and complex because
government is not easy and I won't
pretend that it is
my immediate priority will be to
continue to protect every Scott as far
as we possibly can from the harm
inflicted by the cost of living crisis
to recover and reform our NHS and other
vital public services to support our
well-being economy to improve the life
chances of people right across this
country I will move quickly to develop
plans to extend child care to improve
rural housing support small businesses
and boost Innovation I will bring
forward reforms of the Criminal Justice
System I'll work with local government
to empower our local authorities
and as first Minister I will not shy
away from those exceptionally tough
challenges that require the difficult
decisions
but with this challenge I will use it to
also find opportunity
my government will seize the economic
and social opportunity that the journey
to Net Zero will bring a country is
energy rich as Scotland should not have
people living in fuel poverty the
government I lead will renew and
redouble our efforts to lift people out
of poverty to make work fair to make our
economy work for the people and to
ensure as we become a more prosperous
country we also become a fairer country
too
and while I have had my fair share of
battles with the UK government over the
years and there may well be some to come
I will work with him and other devolved
Nations constructively where I can in
the best interests of our nation
I'm a pro Scot and equally a proud
European too and Scotland is a European
nation we want to return to the European
Union and play our part in building a
continent that's based on human rights
on peace prosperity and social justice
to the people of Scotland the SNP has
earned your trust by governing well by
ensuring that your priorities are our
priorities
as a party and as a government we are at
our best when we are radical and Bold
and the challenges we face today they
require nothing less of us
that is what I promised the people of
Scotland if parliament of course puts
its trust in me tomorrow
joining the SNP for me was an act of
Hope but it was also a statement of
intent I was determined then as I am now
that we will deliver Independence for
Scotland
together
as a team
leadership elections by their very
nature can be bruising however in SNP we
are a family over the last five weeks we
may have been competitors or supporters
of different candidates we are no longer
team Hamza or team Ash or team Kate we
are one team and we will be the team we
will be the generation that delivers
Independence for Scotland
where there are divisions to heal we
must do so quickly because we have a job
to do as a party we are at our strongest
when we are united and what unites us is
our shared goal of delivering
Independence for our nation
to those in Scotland who don't yet quite
share that passion that I do for
Independence I will aim to earn your
trust by continuing to ensure we govern
well and earn your respect as first
Minister by focusing on the priorities
that matter to all of us and in doing so
using our devolved powers to the
absolute maximum effect to tackle the
challenges of the day and for those of
us in this room and watching who do
believe in Independence we will only win
by making that case on the doorsteps and
my solemn promise and commitment to you
is that I will Kickstart our Grassroots
our Civic LED movement and ensure our
drive for Independence is in fifth gear
the people of Scotland need Independence
now more than ever before and we will be
the generation that delivers
Independence for Scotland
before concluding
I want to take the opportunity to thank
some very very special people indeed and
I wouldn't be standing here today if it
wasn't for the support and the
encouragement of a number of
hard-working people
first of all there is my amazing wife
Nadia she is not just my rock she is my
compass who helps to guide me through
the most difficult times in life there
but there is no way not a chance in hell
that I would be standing here if it was
not for your love for your support and
for your advice thank you for believing
me and for always being there for me I
will love you more and I do love you
more than words uh more than the words
that I can find to express to my girls
the this job uh will at times be
all-consuming I suspect but know that
there is no more important job in my
life than being your dad uh to Maya and
Mao you will always always come first
to my mom to my dad to my sisters
thank you for your unwavering support
throughout my life for picking me up
when I have been down and for telling me
to keep going when at times I had my
doubts I'd also like to thank my
phenomenal campaign team you have worked
day and night over the last few weeks to
support me you've all sacrificed time
with your family and your friends
because like me you believe in our
vision of a progressively Progressive
socially just Scotland and I will not
let you down a special mention to Neil
gray that he is quite simply the best
corner man I could have asked for during
the roller coaster of a motion that is
any leadership contest you have been by
my side and there is no way I would have
made it to the Finish Line without your
support and to my good friend and
colleague Shawna Robison your wise
counsel has been indispensable to me
doing this contest
to our now former leader Nicholas
sturgeon and her Deputy in government
John Swinney thank you for your
dedicated service to this party to our
country and to all the people of
Scotland you have left me strong
foundations to build upon
and thank you to my colleagues in both
parliaments across local government and
activists around the country who have
been so supportive and so encouraging I
will assure that I have and I will
ensure that I harness all of the talent
across the party and across the country
as I build that team that will take
Scotland forward to deliver our nation's
independence from our brilliant MPS led
abley by Stephen Flynn and by Mary Black
in Westminster to our leaders in local
government as well as our exceptional
group of msps in the Scottish Parliament
our Parliament has an array of talent
right through its ranks our
parliamentarians our counselors our
activists our members all have a vital
part to play on our journey to
Independence as do our friends right
across the independence movement to have
your confidence as I take on the role as
SMP leader means so much to me
my final thanks is to my grandparents
unfortunately they're no longer alive to
see the state but I'm forever forever
thankful
that my grandparents made the trip from
Punjab to Scotland over 60 years ago
as immigrants to this country who knew
barely a word of English they could not
have imagined in their wildest dreams
that their grandson would one day be on
the cusp of being the next first
minister of Scotland
as Muhammad Yusuf worked in the Singer
sewing machine factory in clydebank
as rahmat Ali Buddha stamped tickets on
the Glasgow Corporation buses
they could not have imagined as I say in
the wildest dreams that two generations
later that their grandson would one day
be on the cusp of being Scotland's first
minister
we should all take pride in the fact
that today we have sent a clear message
that your color of skin or indeed your
faith is not a barrier to Leading the
country that we all call home
from the Punjab to our Parliament this
is a journey over Generations that
reminds us we should be celebrating and
always celebrate the migrants who
contribute so much to our country
this is what drives my commitment to
equality that will underpin my actions
as first minister
thank you for the honor of choosing me
to be your nominee to become to become
Scotland's sixth first Minister I will
dedicate every waking moment to serving
you
the people of Scotland thank you very
much
thank you